decide if you have multiple
opportunities in front of you you have
to decide which one you're going to take
and start taking action on it and not be
held back because you're too afraid to
make the wrong decision and you end up
doing nothing doing nothing is not the
recipe for success I got a question from
a YouTube viewer called a sense of home
who wrote in this age she's got a
passion for decorating she wants to do
an e-book she wants to do magazine she
has tons of ideas she wants to do party
she wants to be in a local TV station
she's got all these goals and ways to
grow her business but she's stuck on
what to do it's great to have tons of
ideas I have a Evernote file full of all
the different is I want to do for my
business some of them never get off that
Evernote sheet and end up deleting them
and I slowly take action on the ones
that I like the most you have to decide
I don't know which one is right for you
I don't know if it's better than TV show
with the e-book or the magazine your
first step with your business if you got
to get to that point of survival I want
to make sure that your business has the
best chance of success and that's going
to happen when you are able to feed
yourself and pay your bills if you have
to shut down because you need money
because your business hasn't generate
anything for you then you're not going
to be successful with your company right
you have to make enough to support
yourself bare bones I'm not talking
luxury talking getting buys you have to
go get a job so look at those
opportunities what's going to get you to
the closest one which one of those will
lead to you being able to survive with
your company then start to chase it it's
great to have a big goal a big dream
that's what keeps you motivated that's
what fuels the long-term growth for your
business have your own TV show great
vision but if that takes a year to get
off the ground and your out of pocket
you may have to go back and go get a job
and quit your business before that ever
comes to fruition so if you're just
starting your business think about
what's going to get you to that point of
survival you're going to get cash flow
coming in you're going to be getting
close to your customers underst
what they need providing amazing service
starting to grow your business getting
some money coming in then from there you
have the luxury to pick where you want
to focus your growth opportunities on I
know it's hard entrepreneurs with
visionary people we love ideas we love
coming up with the new right I'm sure
I'm sure all of you watching is have a
list of ideas and to do is that you wish
you could start touching and playing
with and growing but you have to pick
one and focus on it the danger is either
you don't do anything because you're too
afraid of picking the wrong thing so you
do nothing or you just do all these
little quick starts you start and stop
and start and stop try something else
start and stopping you never actually
build anything pick one focus get to
survival and then you can worry about
the future growth of your business it's
great to have that big vision that
motivates you that inspires you keep it
in your head never lose sight of that
but you got to do the little things to
get you to the poorer survival believe
those are watching you like your video
please give it a thumbs up below it
makes you want to do more for you and
I'd love to hear what you have to think
please leave a comment under this video
if you have a question for your own
company leave it below and I'll make a
video response for you seen your
comments come in really makes my day and
I appreciate it so thank you and I'll
see you soon